le premier maigret que j'ai tourné il ya
12 ans c'était cécile est morte et je me
grey est passé bien sûr à la télévision
car le lendemain matin j'ai téléphoné à
barbe qu'il avait fait je lui dis tu
crois pas que ce serait gentil la lia
quand même dire bonjour à 6 mais non pas
mam dit oui et nous voilà partis
il avait encore sa fameuse maison des
palaces des grandes maisons blanches qui
avait l'air d'une clinique et venant de
signer la série pour la télévision
française je me dissimule on a quand
même donné des tuyaux sur le personnage
de maigret tombé sur un homme très
sympathique très maniaque trésor données
très rangée et il m'a dit qu'une seule
chose il m'a dit voilà quand le
commissaire maigret un sort de chez lui
le matin comment dit-il au revoir madame
maigret il l'embrasserai de joux non
très important petite claque sur les
faces
eh bien avec ce détail précis et
judiciaire ça les gars ça craint